the most valuable thing that you can
build to make money is a brand because a
brand can take two products that are
identical and just slap it on and then
immediately charge a hundred times more
making profit so you can measure the
power of a brand based on how much more
can price above the Commodities in the
same space that is quantifiable so
there's five things you can do to build
it alignment of thoughts words and
action this is meaning you're authentic
associations which is who you roll with
is their brands rub off on you and your
brand rubs off on them Goodwill in terms
of how much you provide value to the
market evidence meaning Jeff Bezos has a
brand because he built Amazon and then
finally is time it's repetition is what
other people think and say about you